Again,
thinking about that,
about in relation to addiction,
I think often when you talk about seeing like work addiction,
right?
Which obviously caused by partly childhood trauma that he experienced,
there's been a real change in how we think about that as well.
It relates back to what you're saying right at the start back chemical hooks,
right?
So if you look at the debate about,
um,
non-drug based addictions,
right?
You think about 20 years ago,
people start talking about sex addiction.
Guy Called Stanton peal,
who were interviewed a lot first writes about love addiction or sources.
Exactly.
Gambling addiction at the time.
Initially what people say,
well this is bullshit because they believed the chemical hooks theory of
addiction.
Right?
Right.
So it just seems like,
well that's not,
I mean there's an episode of chairs actually,
which I'm now would be,
yeah,
you wouldn't do this,
but there's an episode where the whole hilarious premise of the show is that was
the Ted Danson,
Sam Malone,
Ted Danson's character thinks he's a sex addict and this is like a punch line
all the way through the show.
Right?
This was the attitude,
the ends where the goes through on a meeting a sex and love addicts anonymous
and like there's some woman talking about how she gets like have sex with every,
every Madden ends with him just putting his arm around her and that's the end of
the,
the end of the show.
Right.
That wouldn't happen in a sitcom.
Now people,
people thought,
well it might,
but people,
people don't think the very idea of sex addiction is ridiculous in the way they
did.
Right.
I don't think,
I think it's what this,
maybe they do maybe,
but then I think that's because there hasn't been a shift in gamble.
If you got to meeting in gamblers anonymous as I have with a friend,
I don't have a gambling problem,
but just to support someone,
they are as addicted as anyone in the next room down at narcotics anonymous on a
lot of,
not a lot of gambling addicts.
And did you feel that they were as a dictator there?
They're straight up junkies and they might as well be chasing crack.
And that tells us something really important because you don't snort a roulette
wheel,
right?
You don't inject a,
an online poker,
right?
If you can have a professor not said this to me,
if you can have all of the addiction,
but none of the chemical hooks that tells us about how we've overestimated the
role of calories as addiction,
Chemical Hook.
It's a,
there's a dopamine addiction.
Absolutely.
Everything you do that you like,
it gives you dopamine.
It definitely hit.
So I think there's been this attempt to integrate it by going,
oh,
well there's this pleasure in the brain and,
but some sort of self destructive issue.
There's something about gambling,
there's a lot of self hate involved and,
and uh,
this,
this overwhelming feeling of failure that a lot of,
uh,
gambling addicts have because they fail so often and they're,
they're always trying to chase the dragon.
They're always trying to make up for all the past things.
They've gone wrong.
This big score,
well,
this big score,
we're going to settle it out.
And somebody taught me about,
just think about what you're saying in relation to him.
A guy called Peter Cohen,
who is a professor in the Netherlands who actually didn't say this to me
directly.
I [inaudible].
Um,
he says,
we shouldn't call it addiction.
We should call it bonding.
That human beings have an innate need to bond and connect,
right?
And when you're happy and healthy,
you'll bond and connect with like the people around you with meaningful.
But if you can't do that cause you're isolated or traumatized or beaten down by
life,
we haven't been taught how to do that.
You will bond with something that gives you some sense of relief.
Right now,
for some people that might be porn,
for some people that might be gambling,
for some people might be cocaine,
alcohol,
whatever.
It says.
If you,
if you only have one bond that's giving you any relief,
you will obsessive Lee returned to that bond.
Right?
And I don't think that's a total lie.
He,
and as he would say,
that's not a total explanation for what's going on.
But I do think that is a useful way to think about some of these behavioral
addictions.
Right?
So I someone I know very well,
um,
a relative of mine has a gambling addiction and this is someone who has,
okay,
no alternative form of joy or pleasure in their life.
Right?
And
gambling gives a moment among lots of moments of search.
If you look at somebody who's playing online poker is,
I'd done my,
my relative,
they're not happy or it's not looking at someone watching a nice movie,
right?
It's,
you can see,
I don't mean,
I'm sorry I should be up.
Someone with an addiction problem playing online poker.
Some people haven't.
Most people don't have a problem,
right?
Um,
it's the,
it's the relief of just being absent from your life for a moment or for however
long you play,
rather than,
um,
I went to this philosophy,
connections,
my book about depression.
I went to the first ever Internet Rehab Center in the United States.
It's a weird places.
Impressive place such as,
I like the people there.
It's in Spokane,
just outside Spokane in Washington.
It's called restart,
restart Washington.
And I remember going there.
Really,
it was really interesting to think about this.
Um,
I remember arriving,
it's a clearing in the woods,
right?
A big wooden place in clearing the woods.
And I remember absolutely instinctively looking at my phone and feeling really
when a minute I got out the car,
I'm feeling really pissed off.
I can check my email.
Oh wait,
you're in the right place.
Right.
Um,
and it's interesting cause they get all kinds of people and restart Washington,
but they disproportionately get young men who are obsessed with multiplayer role
play games.
Like then it would have been well to walk off now it'd be fortnight and speaking
to these young men,
I'm having this realization,
talking to the woman who runs it is an amazing woman called Dr Hillary cash.
He said to me,
you've got to ask.
I think it relates to it.
You say about gambling,
you got to ask what these young men are getting out of this game because they're
getting something out of it.
Right.
And she argues that one of the things that getting is the things they used to
get from the culture,
but no longer gaps.
Like what?
Well,
I feeling that good at something,
a feeling that other people see them,
that that part of a tribe,
a feeling that they're moving around,
you know,
um,
kids spend very little time outdoors now.
Right?
I think there's also anticipation.
There's puzzles,
there's things where you're trying to figure out whether or not something's
right or wrong and how to get it.
And then if you do get it,
you get this positive surge of you don't get,
I mean,
I think there's human systems that are being
mirrored.
They're in gambling,
what psychologists call,
call that filling of mastery for your master's.
When you feel you are good at something that is an absolutely underlying
psychological need.
Everyone needs to feel they're good at something.
If you don't have a sense of mastery in your life,
you will be depressed and anxious,
right?
Or you're much more likely to become depressed and anxious.
And I think,
again,
because it's so striking to me,
I've got teenage nephews,
I've got sons.
We actually don't ask anything of young men.
Right?
Very rarely are they actually asked to do very much.
They're not given responsibilities.
Right.
I think,
um,
look,
again,
I want to stress the most people playing video games and not dictated.
It's perfectly good form of pleasure,
that very directive.
I mean,
they're not,
most people playing them have a healthy relationship with them in the same way
that I don't know if that's true and can maybe I,
yeah,
tell me about that.
A lot of people playing them have a real problem with them.
They take up massive hours at a time.
It's a giant problem with young boys.
I mean the,
the thing is it's become an actual avenue for career.
Now there's east sports careers where these young guys are making millions of
dollars playing video games.
It's not like the old days where you would say,
hey,
you're wasting your life.
Now it's basically almost like practicing golf.
But we have a setup back here where we play video games against each other.
It's very addictive.
Don't you think it's addictive?
Sure.
Yeah.
So it's like basketball when I was younger too,
I loved playing basketball.
Couldn't get me to play in the rain.
Right.
The basketball has movement and exercise attached to it.
So you get some positive benefit from that addiction.
I was definitely addicted to Jujitsu.
I would even train when I was injured,
you know?
But what does that mean?
It means I enjoyed it more than I enjoyed not doing it.
The difference between a lot of video game addictions and particularly gambling
addictions is that they tend to wreck people's yeah.
Lives.
W you know,
when you had this period of Jujitsu addiction,
did you,
cause they can essentially distinction there.
Where are you doing it to avoid some kind of pain in your life?
Or were you doing it because you just really deeply love it?
It's really,
yeah.
Fun.
Right?
Oh,
so you're chasing the thrill.
I mean,
I'm certain that was avoiding pain with almost everything I've done in my life
in some way,
shape or form.
You know,
there's some of it where you're trying to do something positive to mitigate the
pain or the frustration or the anger or whatever it is that's bothering you.
Um,
but I don't,
you know,
I,
the video game thing was a real addiction though.
It's like a compulsion.
How long was it doing in years?
Yeah.
How did you,
how did you get out of it,
Jay?
I quit.
I just quit cold Turkey,
stop playing.
I realized it was kind of messing up my life and my career.
I was just taking up way too much time and I just,
I came to a realization,
I was like,
I gotta stop doing this.
I'm just playing way too much.
And so I just said,
the only way I,
I'm just too competitive.
I enjoyed it too much.
And so the only way to do it was to stop playing it all together.
And we started playing it again recently after more than Shit,
more than 15 years of ever playing it at all,
you know,
and uh,
it's still addictive,
but I'm so busy now,
I can't really fall into the grip of it.
I'm actually just enjoying for an hour here or there.
But that's so interesting in itself,
isn't it?
That's a bit like the rat park principle.
If there was to me,
correct me if I'm wrong,
that light,
the more you have in your life,
that is meaningful.
That is good.
And it gives you pleasure or sense of mastery,
the less space they will be for these objects of obsession come in.
Right.
And I think that is a principle that's true.
This was the principle behind the Portuguese drug decriminalization,
right?
If we give people good lives,
they will not want to anesthetize themselves so much.
It was the Swiss principle and I think we all see that in our lives to different
degrees.
I,
you know,
the happier I am,
the less I want to turn to,
uh,
you know,
the behaviors that I developed as a child to avoid being present with like
violence and aggression.
Like
I don't think of like writing as an addiction.
It's might be a compulsion if I have a day when I didn't do it,
I feel terrible.
But something that is positive and rewarding,
I don't think is an addiction.
Right?
Something that enriches your life and is not,
it's a way of living life.
The most fulfilling way to session maybe a positive obsession and compulsion and
obsession,
uh,
a way of being in the world,
right?
Like,
I don't,
it's like sometimes I get people saying to me,
you know,
like,
oh,
am I addicted to sex or whatever and you want to say it.
I often say,
well,
does it give you pleasure?
Does it,
is it,
and is it a way of avoiding pain if it gives you pleasure?
And it's not a way of avoiding pain.
It's not an addiction.
It's just a way happy way of being in the world.
Right.
And that's the reality for,
and again,
I think it's really helps us because ti partly what I'm arguing in loss in Las
collections,
I'm chasing the scream,
is we need to deeply reconceptualize how we think about these forms of pain like
depression and addiction.
And this isn't some wacky business,
the view of the World Health Organization,
these leading medical bodies when it comes to depression,
that the,
yeah,
sorry.